i don't usually check my dms on my
instagram you know and
like maybe a week goes by and i actually
look and i have a message from rami
but it wasn't like hey how are you
blah blah blah it was like straight to i
would really appreciate if you take that
down i'm a really private person
awkward rachel bilson reveals that rami
malik
wasn't feeling the throwback pick she
shared from their high school days
it was pretty crazy the 39 year old
actress
posted the snapback in early 2019
when malik was positioned to and later
won
his first oscar for his role as freddie
mercury in bohemian rhapsody
romney was a good friend of mine like we
were all oh he was yeah we were the same
crew
we did the crucible together senior year
we were the leads in it together like
all these things right
we kind of kept in contact a little bit
so obviously he gets super famous
and he's always been extremely talented
a really amazing actor even in high
school
the former oc star opens up about the
whole thing during an appearance on dak
shepard's armchair expert podcast
and describes the pick on a school trip
as quote
the dorkiest picture of both of them bit
of a mess so it's kind of fun
but rachel says the mr robot star didn't
find the post to be
very funny and claims he dm'd her to ask
her to take it down
and i was like what oh okay
okay like i get like really hot i like
start sweating and i'm like
sure they're all nervous like oh my god
like what did i do wilson says her old
pal was less
upset that it was a pic with her and
more bothered by the actual image
i guess he didn't like the picture of
himself and i'm friends with his stylist
and she was like well it's not a great
picture of him and i was like
okay like i'm from high school we were
16.
bilson notes that her oc producer pal
josh schwartz
told her that she quote did him dirty
and she says the whole thing had her
feeling like she posted a controversial
pic
instead of a fun throwback i removed it
and i even wrote to him like a really
nice message like i'm so sorry
go get the oscar like you you're doing
amazing you know and i never hear
anything back which is no
no but i was super bummed because he was
always so nice and we were good friends
and i was just like
i'm a big fan of not taking yourself
seriously especially at that level of
fame and talent but look he wants to be
super respected it's his
thing so i respected it i took it down i
was just a little bummed at how it was
handled
[Music]